I'm farmer Moussa I'm a refugee and also
I'm a mother of two I'm a student and I
would say I'm a photographer I don't
know I'm just a human being
[Music]
I was born in Somalia but I grew up in
Kenya I came here to back in 2004 when I
was 12 years old I met the agile project
when I was in Middle School I was in
eighth grade it's a group of youth and
some adults who are working on improving
the community they teach you how to take
pictures and how to tell your story and
at the same time giving voices to people
who don't have the opportunity to tell
their stories I got fascinated cos I
didn't speak English so I used
photography to tell my story the way I
capture images changed throughout time I
guess at first when I to have the
digital camera it was like you have to
go develop your images and then come
back and then like I don't like that buy
another role and then ticketing it now
you have the deer so large where you
just take a picture and then it
automatically goes to your computer and
before that they had this big computers
to put the memory card in the computer
you have to use a wire and then plug it
it was it was complicated now it's much
simpler photography and technology they
go hand in hand
not having technology is very different
back home we didn't have any cameras we
couldn't just go to the store and buy a
camera even the disposable ones so we
don't have pictures of us younger like
my mom she doesn't care what she look
like back then I don't know what I look
like when I was a baby we don't have any
photos so I wanted to change that for my
kids the farmer was some mother and then
the farmer was a photographer the one
thing they have in common and saving
memories things become history and like
a second so that's why I love taking
pictures all the time
when people think of refugee they don't
go out there to ask a refugee person
every group has like the little box that
people put them in each person has to be
able to tell you who they are and where
they come from a computer gives you a
way to connect with the world I want the
next generation to be open-minded to
follow their dreams not to let anybody
speak for them
you